The more comfortable I get as a
performer over years and years and years
of practicing and performing over and
over again for lots of different
audiences,
the more present I am able to be in the
room.
So instead of losing myself in
performance,
I actually find my exact location in a
very
visceral way.
So I become increasingly aware of
everybody in the audience and what
they're doing.
I know who is falling asleep.
I know who is checking their phone.
I know who is picking their nose.
I know who's wearing a red sweater in
the front row because when I'm nervous,
I can't do that.
Right.
When you're in your head and oh,
I'm performing in,
oh no,
I hope this goes well at it.
Uh,
it's,
it's very difficult to be physically
present with all those people because
it's too much coming at you.
But when I'm in the zone and I'm excited
and I'm tuned into this performance,
I'm able to be very much aware of WHO's
here,
which I think is helpful because it
allows me to be performing specifically
for this room.
The way that I perform for a classroom
of fifth graders is very different from
the way that I perform at a dive bar or
the way that I performed for a stadium
of the rehabs and people.
And it should be,
you should feel a difference in my
performance if you're in the audience
for one of those shows.
So I think when I'm on stage,
if I'm having a great show and I'm
really tuned in,
you can tell because I'm able to be very
much aware and present with the people
in the room and create a show that has
meant for them.
I try to look for opportunities to
communicate that I am in the same room
that they're in.
So if I can make a joke about something
that's happening here or if I have a
reference to what city we're in or if
someone's wearing a tee shirt that I
recognize and can associate with
anything like that is a way of
communicating.
I am in the same space you are and we're
participating in something together,
which also allows some part of an
audience's brain to go,
oh,
I really had to be here.
Which is a nice feeling to have as an
audience member.
It's a way of acknowledging that they've
taken the time to be in this space with
you and you want them to know that
you're aware of that.
Something that I think I will never get
over is the fact that it is a genuine
gift when people are willing to sit in
an audience and give you their time and
attention and breath.
That's something that they could have
spent anywhere else,
but they chose to give it to you here
and it's something that I'm very
cognizant of when I'm on stage and a big
part of what I want to do when I'm
onstage is find a way to acknowledge
those people that have come and are here
in this space and create an environment
that acknowledges that and also rewards
them for that.
How can we attune ourselves?
What's happening in this room so that
later everyone leaves feeling like,
oh,
I really had to be,
I really have to be here for that.
I'm glad I was a part of what happened
tonight.
I had a teacher in college who used to
say that when you're watching a play on
a stage,
if somebody spills a glass of water,
that's the most important thing that
happened in that scene because that
wasn't fake.
Nothing about water spilling is fake.
You see the water and everyone in the
room goes,
that's water and it just spelled and
that's the only thing you can focus on
because that's the most authentic piece
of what's happening in the room right
now.
Or if someone,
if there's an accident and someone gets
hurt,
that's the only thing you can focus on
because it's the most authentic real
thing that's happening in the room.
So I think when people are delivering
content and they're focused only on
themselves,
their delivery,
what they've practiced,
what they rehearsed,
what they've done to the mirror,
and they're not aware of the room.
Oftentimes they're performing in a
vacuum and other people can tell people
in the audience are like,
this isn't for me.
This is for themselves.
This is in their own brains.
I think the most powerful thing people
can do is to spill the glass of water.
Not Literally,
but to find a moment that is real,
to find a moment that is actually
happening here in the room with the
people here to let them know I'm with
you here.
Not In my own vacuum.
Practicing to the mirror somewhere that
what's happening here is a real moment.
And you can create that by acknowledging
something in the room by referencing
something that happened earlier that you
were all witnessed to,
uh,
making a reference to an inside joke
that this group of people all share
based on where you work or where you
live or the weather or what's been
happening in the news.
All of those are ways of genuinely
making something real here as opposed to
hoping that what you prepared in the
past is somehow maybe relevant now.